hallo ich freue mich dass ich dieses
Jahr auch beim Dozierenden Netzwerk
etwas beitragen darf und dass ich heute
hier sein kann na ja so richtig hier bin
ich ja nicht es ist ja eine synchrone
Aufzeichnung die Sie jetzt hier sehen
werden aber passt ja irgendwie zu
unserem Thema mit der Zeit
da hat sich ja so einiges getan mit den
technischen Möglichkeiten die es heute
gibt und nachdem ich leider heute nicht
selber da sein kann also für sie ist
heute für mich ist es morgen
habe ich eben ja in meinem Vortrag heute
aufgezeichnet das sieht dann eben heute
sehen können
interessanterweise gut dann teile dich
mal mein Bildschirm und freue mich dass
ich ein bisschen was über das Thema der
Veranstaltungsplanung sagen kann und das
ist eben ein sehr
praxisorientierte Vortrag den ich heute
habe
eigentlich wirklich daraus entstanden
aus sehr vielen Kursen die ich gebe zum
Thema lehrveranstaltungsplanung
Hochschuldidaktik Zeitmanagement diese
ganzen Dinge und nachdem ich ja eben
nicht da sein kann live würde ich mich
freuen wenn es irgendwelche Fragen oder
Kommentare zu dem Vortrag gibt gerne an
mich zu senden und der
sabrina-sontheimer@comkult.de da können
Sie mich jederzeit erreichen ich freue
mich über Austausch in den Bereich total
ja mein Thema was von der Lehrzeit übrig
bleibt der Lehrveranstaltungen
realistisch planen nun kommt wie gesagt
sehr stark aus meiner Tätigkeit als
hochschuldidaktische Trainerinnen und
Zeitmanagement und
Kommunikationstrainerin und auch
Trainerin zum Thema wissenschaftliches
Schreiben ich berate da auch sehr viel
in der Universität in der LM
Lehrende Studierende in Bezug auf das
Schreiben und mir ist aufgefallen dass
es eigentlich immer wenn es
Zeitmanagement Probleme gibt
so ganz bestimmte Gründe die dazu führen
eigentlich die Sohle schreiben einfach
einen Plan von Veranstaltungen ziemlich
ähnlich sind und da würde ich jetzt
gerne mal ein bisschen drüber sprechen
und die Frage die ich mich mir erstmal
so gestellt habe ist was ist eigentlich
das übliche Vorgehen bei der
kursvorbereitung und da könnte man sagen
das erste was man normalerweise tut ist
dass man wie so ein Eichhörnchen
eigentlich erstmal Themen und Inhalt
sammeln also man sammelt so seine
Nüsschen zusammen sammeln sammeln
sammelt und versucht dann diese Nüsschen
irgendwie unterzubringen ja also diese
ganzen Inhalte die ich mir anfuttere für
den Winter ich lese unglaublich viel rum
ich möchte ganz viele Inhalte
reinbringen und meinen Studierenden
vermitteln und wenn ich jetzt eben sehr
viele Nüsse gesammelt habe kommt eben zu
dem Problem dass man die Nuss vor lauter
Nüssen nicht mehr sind ja also wenn man
sich dann so vorstellt man hat so eine
90 Minuten
Vorlesung oder oder ein Seminar und
irgendeiner Art von Veranstaltung das
ist der Rahmen diese 90 Minuten und dann
will jetzt eigentlich diese ganzen
Inhalte in diese
Veranstaltung rein Batzen sozusagen also
das ganze Nüsse die man vorher gesammelt
hat sollen da irgendwie rein ja weil man
ja so viele Ideen hat Informationen
gesammelt hat die irgendwie alle
untergebracht werden wollen oder man
will sie selber eben auch unterbringen
also weiß nicht wie es da Ihnen geht
aber ich bin da schon so jemand wenn ich
so ganz viele spannende Themen habe ich
möchte dann auch da einfach ganz viel
rüberbringen dass die Leute auch viel
mitnehmen können und das ist wirklich
oftmals so eine gewisse Form des
Rheinbad sind weil man sich denkt oh das
ist so spannend das muss irgendwie auch
noch mal rein
es gibt hier so zwei verschiedene große
Einflussfaktoren die man dabei ein
bisschen berücksichtigen muss ja wenn
man einfach mal so diese diese Nüsschen
so reinwarzen so lässt sich also ganz
vorher also die ganzen Veranstaltungen
man hat das eigentlich die
lehrkonzeption an sich schon ein
entscheidenden Einfluss darauf hat wie
ich da mit meiner Zeit umgehen kann also
wenn wir eher Lehrenden zentriert
arbeiten also sowas wie bei einer
Vorlesung vom Lernenden Vortrag oder
auch in so Seminaren wo man selber im
Dialog vielleicht sehr viel präsentiert
vorstellt
Dinge einordnet und und selber eben als
Lehrende so den Tag sehr statt vorgibt
hat man natürlich ein Thema Zeitplanung
weniger ein Problem also das ist sehr
effizient weil man viele innerhalb
unterbringt es ist planbar weil ich mir
genau überlegen kann was will ich denn
unterbringen ich bin unabhängig von
anderen und kann eben da selber managen
was kommen sie dann rein wie viel davon
generational weil ich eben darüber so
ein bisschen eine Kontrolle vorher habe
und eher weniger störungsanfällig aber
je stärker das in die
studierendenzentrierung geht kann man
sagen dass es viel zeitintensiver wird
weil man eben dann ja sich darauf
einlassen muss was die anderen Leute so
tun es ist weniger planbar weil die
natürlich auch Reaktion haben die ich
nicht so ganz erwarte wir müssen eher
kooperativ und interaktiv denken und
wenn die Leute eben dann mitarbeiten
haben wir genauso das Problem die
Arbeiten vielleicht nicht so wie wir die
haben andere Strategien andere
Lösungswege brauchen vielleicht auch
länger weil sie eben Studierende sind
und nicht solche Experten wie wir
zusätzlich kommen noch dieses ganze
emotionale mit dazu es ist Menschheit
wenn die Leute überfordert sind
gestresst sind gelangweilt demotiviert
kann ja viele Gründe haben worum es dann
doch ein bisschen Zähler ist oder warum
Störungen überhaupt entstehen also es
ist dadurch auch einfach störungsanfälle
egal
also diese Lehrenden oder
studierendenzentrierung hat eben ganz
großen Einfluss darauf wie viel Zeit ich
tatsächlich
von sinnvoll oder was heißt sinnvoll
aber voll packen kann mit Inhalten oder
eben wo ich auch andere Dinge mit
berücksichtigen muss wenn wir uns das
mal anschauen verschiedene
lehrkonzeptionen mit diesen Rahmen als
wenn wir so eine 90 Minuten vor
Vorlesungen Referate Seminar oder andere
Seminar haben dieses Konzept oder dieses
diese Vorgaben von der Lehrveranstaltung
da sind so typische Zeitplanungen so bei
einer Vorlesung hätte man dann kurzes
Intro vielleicht so ein willkommen in
einem Überblick was Thema dann einen
sehr langen Lehrenden Vortrag in dem
informiert wird das könnten dann schon
fast 84 Minuten sein wenn man es eben
wirklich durchzieht am Ende gibt's
vielleicht so ein kleines Ding noch
fragen wenn man keine Zeit mehr hat was
man gar nicht mehr auf die Antworten oft
sind die Leute dann so platt dass sie
dann auch gar keine Fragen mehr haben
und dann am Ende gibt es noch mal ein
kleines Auto ja wir sehen uns nächste
Woche also das natürlich der Extremfall
also oft sind ja natürlich noch mal ein
bisschen mehr Raum für Fragen vielleicht
auch mal fragen zwischendrin
wesentliches aber das bei so einer sehr
Lehrenden zentrierten Veranstaltung
dieses informieren über den Lehrern den
Vortrag natürlich sehr viel Raum
einnimmt oder immer dann schon
nebeneinander
umfangreichen Minutenzahl kann man sagen
was für uns in der englischen
Literaturwissenschaft zum Beispiel sehr
typisch ist ist ein Referate Seminar
sehr oft den Geisteswissenschaften ja
vor allem gern gesehenes Formen Format
der Seminare dass eben Studierenden
Referat halten und dann danach wird
darüber diskutiert da war auch kleines
Intro und Outro dann kommt es diese
informieren Phase eben ist schon ein
bisschen kürzer also wirklich wo es rein
um die Inhalte geht zu 15 bis 20 Minuten
ist da ja oft der Standard und dann
kommt eben ein relativ großer Block noch
mal mit Diskussion was ja in die
Richtung verarbeiten geht aber trotzdem
auch Inhalte dann wieder erarbeitet
werden
bei einem Seminar was wir eben ja immer
so auch unterstützen dass man eben
interaktiv kompetenzorientiert nutzt da
gibt es ja dieses Aviva Schema was viele
hier auch einfach kennen was bei Profil
auch bei uns ja viel gelehrt wird dieses
Schema wie man Seminare Kompetenz
orientiert aufbaut nach Städeli und ein
paar anderen Kollegen die eben dieses
Modell entwickelt haben gibt auch andere
Modelle manchmal heißt auch Ariva es
gibt auch Kollegen die Ulrike Handke die
hat einen ähnliches Modell das ist nennt
sich mombi also das in verschiedene
Varianten dazu
aber da geht's eben immer darum dass
diese informieren Phase eigentlich
eingebettet ist in das was lernen eben
auch unterstützen kann in eine
ausrichten Phase wo die Leute orientiert
werden dann wird erstmal Vorwissen
aktiviert damit die Leute die neuen
Informationen alles Vorwissen Andenken
können dann kommt eben das Informieren
von den über den neuen Inhalte das
Verarbeiten dieser Inhalte ganz wichtig
bei der Kompetenz Orientierung dass die
Leute mit diesem Wissen auch was machen
müssen das ist nicht nur so ist wir
schmeißen den Leuten müssen hin und dann
müssen sie das irgendwie
wissen und kennen sondern dass sie auch
was damit tun müssen das muss dann am
Ende auch anwenden können und am Ende
noch mal so eine auswerten Phase wo man
dann immer noch mal über den
Lernfortschritt reflektiert und das
ganze zivildient von Abschluss bringt
also man sieht schon hier ist das eben
auch viel stärker sozusagen Richtung
Studierenden Zentrierung wenn man eben
zu diesen Aviva Seminaren rüber geht und
da ist dieser reinen informieren Block
also wo es wirklich darum geht Inhalte
reinzubringen dann schon mal wesentlich
geringer
wenn man sich eben dann stärker auf
einzelne Inhalte fokussieren sollte und
muss damit man die eben sozusagen
intensiver bearbeitet dass die Leute
sind gut behalten können tatsächlich
was nicht heißt das Vorlesung an sich
nicht schlechtere Variante wäre es
funktioniert nur anders also da muss die
Verarbeitungsphase dann eben irgendwie
außerhalb vonstatten gehen dass die
Leute das dann irgendeiner Form dann
auch anwenden können
aber allein für die
lehrveranstaltungsplanung hat es eben da
schon Unterschied also diese türkisen
Blöcke werden jetzt sozusagen also die
Anteile von dieser reinen
Wissensvermittlung und die ist eben in
der mehr Lehrenden zentrierten Variante
viel größer als eben in der mehr
studierendenzentrierten Variante
aber das ist nur die eine Seite also das
ist wirklich so diese typische
Zeitplanung die aber schon sehr stark
noch auf dieser Theorie eigentlich fußt
und jetzt komme ich zu meinem
eigentlichen Thema und zwar was dann
noch so alles mit reinkommt und zwar die
Einflussfaktoren die man gar nicht so
auf dem Schirm hat also diejenigen die
über die man eigentlich nie nachdenkt
und das ist mir alles erst eigentlich
auch so jetzt immer im Laufe der Arbeit
gekommen und ich habe mir mal so eine
ganz tolle Übersicht gemacht dazu wie
viel eigentlich damit rein fließt und
das ist wirklich ich habe das mal riesen
Mindmap erstellt was eigentlich so
Faktoren sind die man nicht so auf dem
Schirm hatte die ganze Zeit und ich
mache das jetzt mal so ein bisschen
strukturiert in eigentlich so fünf
Blöcke was was man wirklich nicht so auf
dem Schirm hat das erste wäre so diese
ganze orientierungszeit also die kann an
verschiedenen Stellen von so einer
Veranstaltung auftreten also sowas wie
diese Zeit wo man erstmal eine Agenda
vorstellt den Zeitplan
vielleicht auch
Kommunikationsregeln wie wollen wir
miteinander arbeiten zum Beispiel auch
in der online-lehre ganz wichtig dann
sowas wie Neugier wecken dass man die
Leute erst mal irgendwie packt irgendwie
ein Beispiel bringt was Sie vielleicht
aus ihrer eigenen eigenen Lebenswelt
kommen
erkennen um eben sie da überhaupt mal
abzuholen wo sie stehen
wenn man dann eben dann schon bei der
Arbeit ist und mit den Leuten wirklich
interagiert sowas wie Aufgabenstellungen
erklären also das ist ja auch meistens
das was man in so einer
Veranstaltungsplanung gar nicht so mit
drin hat also wieder brauche ich
eigentlich um den zu erklären dass sie
jetzt ein Poster erstellen sollen
wie soll dieses Poster aussehen was soll
damit passieren was was was
erwarte ich eben anhalten auf diesem
Poster das sind alles Dinge die in diese
orientierungszeit mit reingehen die man
eben auch mal in Minuten abziehen muss
wo ich den Leuten erstmal erkläre was
sie überhaupt zu tun haben
der zweite Punkt wer diese soziale Zeit
die man tatsächlich mit einberechnen
sollte weil die eigentlich fürs Lernen
ja unglaublich wichtig ist wir wissen ja
nach dies den Ryan auch dass Motivation
beim Lernen oder eben gutes Lernen auch
durch kooperative also Kooperation
stattfindet also kooperatives Lernen man
soll zusammenarbeiten um da eben weiter
zu kommen und damit es funktioniert sind
eben diese ganzen sozialen kleinen Dinge
so unglaublich wichtig also sowas wie so
ein kleines Warm Up am Anfang von einer
Stunde damit die Leute halt auch einfach
irgendwie dabei sind so eisbreaker z.B
auch das mit der Neugier hat da so ein
bisschen damit zu tun aber eben mehr auf
der sozialen Ebene dass die Leute halt
dann so ein bisschen auftauen und eben
dabei sind da gehört auch Smalltalk dazu
einfach mal so ein bisschen Chat am
Anfang ähm ja geht's euch denn so was
soll was ist denn gerade so Thema oder
was beschäftigt euch gerade
wollen nur so ein zwei Minuten sein aber
einfach nur um da so eine lockere
Atmosphäre zu schaffen dann auch so eine
wichtige Phase des Kennenlernens gerade
wenn es um kooperatives Arbeiten geht
sollte irgendwo eine Phase auftauchen wo
die Leute sich wirklich kennenlernen
also ich mache in meinen Kursen
eigentlich immer die erste Sitzung ist
eigentlich fast nur Teambuilding ja weil
man sich ja auch überlegen muss wenn
Leute in der Gruppe sind und dann Sachen
sagen sollen wo sie selber eigentlich
schwimmen weil es wirklich komplexe
Theorie ist oder schwierig Gedankengänge
tut man sich leichter wenn man die Leute
kennt und ein Vertrauen zu ihnen hat und
irgendwo sollte man mal Zeit finden
diese Vertrauen überhaupt aufzubauen
also nicht nur zwischen einem selber als
Lehrende und den Studierenden sondern
auch den Studierenden untereinander dass
die Vertrauen zueinander haben dass sie
da halt auch mal was doofes sagen können
dass man sieht aha hier herrscht eine
angenehme Fehlerkultur das ist auch okay
wenn man wenn ich mal was blödes sagen
dass man überhaupt einen Beitrag dann
leistet
auch so dass man mal ins Reden kommt ja
dass die Leute überhaupt dann so so
miteinander überhaupt ähm interagieren
wollen und ihm auch die Zeit bis man
überhaupt ins Reden kommt ist auch so
ein soziale Zeit ja also dass man halt
überhaupt
sich selber dein Herz fast um dann
überhaupt auf eine Frage zu antworten
zu dieser sozialen Zeit gehört auch
sowas dass ich als lehrpersönlichkeit so
ein bisschen sichtbar werde also dass
ich mal vielleicht einen Witz mache dass
ich meine Story erzähle ich erzähle mal
ganz gerne so auch wirklich aus meinem
Alltag irgendwas was ich jetzt letzte
Woche wieder so absurdes erlebt habe
oder so dass die Leute einfach mal sehen
ja das ist ein Mensch der da steht und
das dadurch einfach auch so eine
lockerere Stimmung entsteht dass die
Leute eben da wieder Vertrauen haben und
eben sich auch beteiligen wollen dadurch
oder auch in Metaphern irgendwas zu
erklären ja also dass man irgendwelche
Bilder aufbringt ja das ist eben nicht
nur inhaltlich was erklärt wird sondern
dass man ihn mal ein bisschen ausholt
und mit der Vogel irgendwas erklärt
damit die Leute sie einfach besser
verstehen das wäre alles so auf dieser
sozialen Ebene wo Zeit drauf geht kann
man sagen um diesen
gesellschaftlichen Klebstoff nennt man
das glaube ich irgendwie also dass man
das irgendwie mit rein bringt dass die
Leute dann tatsächlich auch gut
miteinander arbeiten und dann auch eben
die Arbeitsergebnisse besser sind weil
die Leute dann halt auch aktiver mit
dabei sind und so eine gewisse ähm ja
ähm
eine Eigenverantwortung spüren für die
Gruppe
das dritte ist das Thema
Vorbereitungszeit also wie oft denkt man
darüber nach wie lange die Leute
brauchen nicht nur um Dinge wirklich zu
bearbeiten also wenn wir mal das Poster
Beispiel nehmen wie lange brauchen die
um über also die die Inhalte wirklich
aufs Poster zu bringen sondern auch so
Dinge wie wenn die dann in einem kleinen
Gruppe zusammenarbeiten dann gibt es
normalerweise immer erstens so ein
bisschen Smalltalk vielleicht ein
bisschen ein updaten was sie gerade
irgendwie in der Mensa gegessen haben
oder so einfach mal um überhaupt als
Gruppe auch ins Reden zu kommen die
brauchen auch so ihre wurmabzeit
eigentlich innerhalb der Gruppe also wer
fängt denn da so direkt an ja meistens
wird man erstmal noch mal ein bisschen
erstmal ein bisschen Smalltalk machen
oder auch mal rumblättern in den
Unterlagen wenn man noch mal was
nachschauen muss oder das Material
herrichten bei so einem Poster ja als
ich die Stifte zurechtlegen oder
überhaupt mal angucken was habe ich
überhaupt zur Verfügung um eben dieses
Poster zu erstellen dann auch wie viel
denkzeit gebe ich den Leuten bevor sie
überhaupt miteinander kooperieren können
weil nur weil die Leute jetzt eine
Aufgabe bekommen erwartet man ja oft man
dass die dann gleich miteinander reden
aber vielleicht müssen die da auch
erstmal drüber nachdenken für sich
selber was sie da überhaupt auf so einem
Poster machen würden wie sollen so
Poster dann aussehen welche Farben
nehmen wir das da jetzt welche Inhalte
brauchen wir dazu das braucht alles
einfach Zeit auch sowas wie die Rollen
im Team verteilt sind also wer macht
denn was wer schreibt denn jetzt wer
macht so ein bisschen die Moderation wer
präsentiert danach das sind alles so
Dinge die damit reinkommen die man auch
eigentlich wenig auf dem Schirm hat
und das wäre auch manchmal so nicht nur
das Denken sondern auch das reden das
ist sowas auch so eine Art
Vorbereitungszeit so ein drumrum reden
dass man manchmal wenn man ja so bei
Studierenden Gruppenarbeiten zuhört sich
denkt er wusste wo sind die denn jetzt
gerade das hat ja gar nichts mit dem
Thema zu tun so richtig das ist irgendwo
ganz woanders aber weil natürlich man
nicht sofort ja immer auf den Punkt
genau weiß was jetzt wichtig ist und was
Priorität hat und was inhaltlich einfach
der Schwerpunkt ist weil sie ja eben
keine Experten und Expertinnen sind und
dann muss man vielleicht das erstmal
auch so einkreisen und drüber reden und
drüber reden und irgendwann kommt man
dann so zu dem Punkt wo man eigentlich
hin wollte und das braucht natürlich
auch wieder Zeit auch so ganz einfache
Dinge wie dass sie am Ende Aufstehen das
Poster aufhängen oder nach vorne kommen
und sich dann eben einigen wäre das Ding
jetzt dann präsentiert das sind alles
Zeiten die man eigentlich in
Vorbereitungszeit ja auch mit
berücksichtigen sollte ja bei so einem
also alleine neben dieser Schreibzeit
oder wirklich dieser tatsächlichen
Arbeit ja alles was so drumherum geht
genauso wenn man sich sowas denkt wie
wenn ich eine Frage stelle dass die
Leute vielleicht eine denkzeit brauchen
um über die Frage nachzudenken um sie
dann wirklich zu beantworten oder auch
sowas wie das wenn man sich manchmal so
aufregt dass Studierende nicht auf den
Punkt kommen es gibt ja manchmal so
Leute die reden und reden und reden und
irgendwie denkt man sich sowas soll denn
das jetzt ist in 5 Minuten Beitrag und
wir haben doch keine Zeit aber am Ende
ist es so dass natürlich dieses reden
darüber natürlich auch das Denken
fördert und dann die Leute erstmal zum
Punkt kommen werden Sie darüber reden
geht mir selber ganz genauso dass ich
oft einfach mal Rede und irgendwann
komme ich dann schon zu der Idee die ich
eigentlich ausdrücken wollte das ist
manchmal einfach so und da reden ist
auch dann denken und das ist auch ein
Teil der bei so Diskussion oft nicht
berück sichtigt wird das Leute
vielleicht auch erstmal reden muss
müssen um überhaupt einen Gedanken zu
fassen
als nächster Punkt Pausen auch sowas was
man oft nicht so ganz am Schirm hat aber
ich würde auch immer sagen eigentlich
was ich so als Lehrende festgestellt
habe ist so nach 60 bis 70 Minuten
könnte man sagen ist schon ziemlich
ziemlich lang für Leute eben dann
konzentriert zu sein man hat meistens so
ein Gefühl dass irgendwann der Zeit
werden die Leute schon so unruhig und es
fängt schon irgendwie rundherum das
Rascheln an das ist die Zeit wo man
definitiv eine Pause einlegen soll und
wenn es auch nur ein paar Minuten sind
aber es ist immer gut sich dann mal kurz
das Hirn durchzupusten sollte man auch
mit einplanen auf jeden Fall
man braucht vielleicht nicht ganz so
radikal machen wie bei der Promodoro
Technik dass man 25 Minuten arbeitet und
5 Minuten Pause macht gibt ja eben diese
Theorie aber nichtsdest du weniger
regelmäßige Pausen machen auf jeden Fall
Sinn um eben da auch wieder die die
Leute
einfach mal wieder abzuholen einfach in
dem dass sie dass sie wieder
konzentriert werden ja und dass man ihn
dann eine kurze Ruhepause gönnt dass sie
da eben dann wieder mit einsteigen
können aber diese Pausen müssen
natürlich zeitmäßig auch mit eingeplant
werden und wenn man sie nicht beeinplant
hat man eben das Problem dass eben die
Konzentration sinkt und dann dauert
sowieso alles immer länger also Pausen
sind am Ende dann eigentlich wieder ein
Effizienz stärken aber nichts ist so
weniger ist es natürlich Zeit die auch
irgendwie dann verloren geht könnte man
sagen
und als letzter großer Punkt Störungen
wie gehen wir mit Störungen um also der
Klassiker ist natürlich das Handy ja da
kann natürlich alles mögliche an Unruhe
mit dabei sein wenn Leute eben
miteinander gerade reden auf das ist ja
auch gar nichts Negatives wenn die
während ich vorne was erzähle dann auch
noch miteinander reden manchmal sind sie
vielleicht abgelenkt kann aber auch
manchmal sein dass sie irgendwie
wirklich was diskutieren was ich gerade
gesagt habe oder eine Nachfrage haben
weil sie nicht mitgekommen sind das kann
nicht Störung sein oder auch andere
Ablenkungen sowas hat man ja manchmal in
der online-lehre oft immer wenn Katzen
durchs Bild laufen ich weiß nicht ob sie
das auch schon mal festgestellt haben
aber dann achtet niemand mehr worum es
geht wenn hier irgendwie im an der
Kamera ist und sind alle bei der Katze
oder beim Hund oder was auch immer
und dann kann man eigentlich total
vergessen dass man da noch irgendwie
weitermacht aber solche Störungen kommen
halt eben auch dazu in Präsenz kann es
immer noch ein Bagger sein der draußen
vor der Tür rumfährt ja es ist alles
möglich die Technik ist auch immer so
was sei das jetzt eben die der Beamer
oder online eben auch das Zoomen was
eben nicht funktioniert ich hatte jetzt
erst jetzt wieder eine schöne Erfahrung
mit MSP Teams ja wo man auch sagt ja
vielen Dank da brauche ich gar nicht
anfangen
solche technischen Schwierigkeiten
können immer mit dazu kommen hat mir da
in dem Kurs z.B gleich eine
Viertelstunde gekostet auch ganz toll
wenn man eben mit solchen Störungen
umgehen muss und die eben nicht so
richtig im Plan hat können auch
Missverständnisse sein also
Missverständnisse wenn ich irgendwas
erkläre und die Leute das ganz anders
verstehen und bis man das mal aufgeklärt
hat z.B also Aufgabenstellungen deswegen
Aufgabenstellungen am besten auch immer
visualisieren irgendwo hinterlegen als
Bild als PDF als Ausdruck oder so dass
die Leute noch mal nachschauen kann
sonst kommen meistens eher fünf Fragen
und es dauert dann auch immer viel
länger
wichtig bei Störungen Störungen haben
immer Vorrang ja gibt es ja diesen
tollen Spruch und den den der es
wirklich war weil sobald eine Störung da
ist die Leute sich eigentlich nicht mehr
auf die Inhalte konzentrieren können und
deswegen auf jeden Fall auf die Störung
reagieren aber wenn ich eben reagiere
und damit umgehen muss dann muss ich das
natürlich auch wieder irgendwie
unterbringen in meiner Zeit und das sind
eben schon mal fünf große Bereiche wo
man mal drüber nachdenken sollte habe
ich das im vorhinein schon mal irgendwie
berücksichtigt dass diese Störungen
geben kann so wie geht man jetzt mit
diesem ganzen
Einfluss diesen ganzen Zeit der Faktoren
um wenn es ihm nicht nur um die Inhalte
geht sondern um so viel nicht Zeit oder
Meter Zeit die da eigentlich auch noch
mit rein fließt und da hätte ich auch
noch mal drei
Maßnahmen sozusagen die man da ergreifen
kann das erste wäre natürlich die
Einplanung von
der geschätzte Lothar Seibert ist ja so
kann man sagen so der Papst unter den
Zeitmanagement
Trainern oder Speakern Moderatoren wie
auch immer und der hat ja diese schöne
60 40 Regeln aufgestellt in der alten
Methode dass man eben 60% der Zeit der
Arbeitszeit verplanen sollte und 40
Prozent als Puffer wo eben dann 20%
widerspontanes sein können von diesen 40
und 20% unvorhergesehen ist das klingt
immer so unglaublich viel aber
tatsächlich muss man echt sagen das
macht schon Sinn ein Puffer einzuplanen
auf jeden Fall ein Puffer ob es 40% sein
müssen das muss man dann eben immer
selber noch mal sehen geht das überhaupt
aber ihr mehr Puffer wie weniger also
weil das ist meistens so dass die Puffer
recht schnell eben aufgetaucht sind und
alles was ich ihm vorher erzählt habe
würde eben dann über so ein Puffer auch
gut aufgefangen werden also ich bin
mittlerweile wirklich rüber gegangen
eine sehr Rico große Zeitplanung zu
machen und das ist eben gleich mein
zweiter Punkt was tun das
bottom-up-verfahren nicht das jetzt
nenne weil eben haben wir gehört dass
meistens so ist ich mache mir Gedanken
über die Inhalte und dann schaue ich was
habe ich für eine Zeit und schmeißt die
Inhalte sozusagen in diese Zeit rein und
dann ist es das was rauskommt aber und
also von oben nach unten also ich habe
meine Inhalte und möchte sie dann rein
Formen sozusagen in die Zeit aber
eigentlich wird es mehr Sinn machen von
unten rauf zu gehen also was ist
sozusagen bei von diesen Rahmen
überhaupt schon vorgegeben oder Wasser
sind dafür Zwänge da genau das was ich
eben schon gesagt habe also mal von
unten her zu denken nicht von den
Inhalten sondern von dem Framework also
von diesen ganzen Meter und nicht Seiten
die wir besprochen haben wenn wir eben
diese 90 Minuten haben
sie schon mal immer diese Pause ab hier
also es wir brauchen irgendwo
zwischendrin mal kurz ein paar Minuten
Pause 5 Minuten bei drei Stunden zweimal
10 Minuten oder 15 Minuten oder wie auch
immer ich habe ein Puffer hinten dran
noch mal dann habe ich immer so Intro
und Outro ja dass ich Intro Ziele Agenda
vorstellen Abschluss schaffen das sind
schon mal alles so Zeiten wo eigentlich
eher nichts passiert ähm das ist nicht
zeitlich tatsächlich schon mal ab
genauso wie so Smalltalk am Anfang ich
mittlerweile weiß ich eigentlich dass
keine Veranstaltung super pünktlich
losgeht sondern es dauert immer
mindestens zwei drei Minuten eher fünf
bis alle beieinander sind und dass man
sagt so und jetzt fangen wir eigentlich
mal richtig an
dann auch sowas wie dieses Warmup das
kann kürzer oder länger sein je nachdem
wie gut sich die Gruppe kennt und dann
sind wir eben erst hier bei den
Zeiten die dann eigentlich noch übrig
bleiben ja wenn wir das einfach mal
abrechnen und da ist man wenn man das
jetzt eben bei sag mal ich habe ganz oft
so drei Stunden Slots eigentlich rechne
ich deine eine Stunde weg ja dass man
sagen kann mit Pausen mit Abschluss mit
einem Intro mit Smalltalk Blabla und
Puffer ist eigentlich schon mal eine
Stunde komplett weg und dann habe ich
eigentlich noch zwei Stunden Inhalt den
ich da verplanen kann als Beispiel und
das ist eben auch so deswegen habe ich
das jetzt so ein bisschen schattiert
gemacht das weiße wer sozusagen wirklich
noch die inhaltszeit es ist eben auch da
immer wenn wir da jetzt noch mal vor
Wissen aktivieren informieren
verarbeiten reflektieren das sind alles
solche
Mischungen dass wir da eben
Inhalte vermitteln aber dann diese
ganzen fünf Schritte die vorhin schon
gesagt habe die da auch noch Einflüsse
sind also die Störungen und so weiter
fließende immer noch mit rein also was
wir am Ende haben und das ist eben jetzt
der dritte Aspekt ist eben das am Ende
eigentlich was übrig bleibt von dieser
Zeit ist eigentlich nur eine Nuss oder
sagt man ein paar wenige Nüsse ja also
die Reduktion von Inhalten und von
Ansprüchen und zwar wirklich radikal
dass ich wirklich weniger mache das
Versuche genauer zu machen dass Leute es
besser verstehen dass da dann eher ein
Transfer zustande kommt als wenn ich
sozusagen alles mögliche reinpacke und
dann am Ende sowieso immer zeitlich
nicht hinkomme weil eben Störungen
auftreten es eben soziale Sachen gibt
irgendwelche Einflüsse die da reinkommen
und man dann eh nicht zu diesen ganzen
Dingen kommt und dann eben auch nicht
immer tausend Dinge vorbereiten muss
also ich versuche mittlerweile wirklich
mir erst überlegen wie viel effektive
Zeit habe ich denn wirklich und wenn ich
bei den drei Stunden Workshop weiß
bleiben dann nur zwei Stunden oder
eineinhalb überhaupt übrig wo ich
überhaupt mal an Inhalte denken kann und
dann wie gesagt mit Aufgaben dann habe
ich vielleicht noch einen interaktive
verarbeitungsaufgabe damit wo die dann
irgendwie eine Dreiviertelstunde Breaker
drum sind dann wird schon sehr
zusammengestaucht was an Inhalten
überhaupt reingeht und da muss man eben
dann ganz stark priorisieren also was
sind denn wirklich die wirklich
wichtigen Dinge und was sind die nice to
have ja und dann muss man eben so rum
wieder denken dass man erstmal sagt ich
muss eben die ganz wichtigen Sachen die
ich sowieso schon im Kopf habe dass die
ganz wichtig sind die müssen erst mal
rein und alles andere kann danach eben
kommen und das ist eben genau diese
Verbindung die ich auch ein bisschen
schaftlichen schreiben Sie das Leute
dann eben oft sammeln sammeln sammeln
und am Ende wollen sie dann da eine
Doktorarbeit oder eine Seminararbeit
schreiben je nachdem die hat vielleicht
dann die Doktorarbeit soll vielleicht
sogar mal 200 Seiten haben oder sowas
und dann dass man sich ja eben mal
überlegen wie was hat man überhaupt da
man hat eben dann irgendwie 20 Seiten
Intro 20 Seiten outro dann hat man
irgendwie noch 160 Seiten übrig dann
möchte man fünf Kapitel schreiben das
sind dann ca 30 Seiten pro Kapitel und
wenn man so denkt dann weiß man dass es
irgendwie keinen Sinn macht 100.000
Abstracts zu sichten und tausend Texte
zu lesen und dann am Ende einfach viel
zu viel zu haben dass man gar nicht
reinbringen also von diesem Eisberg der
wichtig ist dieser Wissens Eisberg den
man sich erstmal abarbeitet aber da
kommt ja nur die ganz Kleinen Spitze
dann am Ende des paper rein genauso wie
der Veranstaltung und diese Eisberg ist
wichtig aber man braucht eben dann
vielleicht schon im Vorfeld gar nicht
den Eisberg so riesig zu machen sondern
man kann schon ein bisschen
realistischer an die Sache rangehen wenn
ich weiß da passen sowieso nur 30 Seiten
in dieses Kapitel oder passt sowieso nur
20 Seiten wirklichen Vortrag wo ich
Inhalte präsentiere in diese Lehrer
Veranstaltung
ich hoffe dass es ihnen ein bisschen
geholfen hat für ihre zukünftigen
Lehrveranstaltungen ein bisschen mehr
diese nicht- und Meter Zeiten mit zu
berücksichtigen und die sagt wenn sie
noch Kommentare und Fragen haben können
Sie mir gerne schreiben und ansonsten
sage ich herzlichen Dank fürs zuhören
und ich hoffe sie und ihr habt noch eine
schöne Tagung und anregende Diskussion
vielen Dank